booktv.org
now here's steve call on the cia's
clandestine operations in afghanistan
and pakistan
good afternoon
good afternoon and welcome i'm steve
levingston non-fiction book editor of
the washington post
which is a charter sponsor of the
national book festival
first a couple of housekeeping things
we'd like to extend a word of thanks to
the festival's co-chairman david
rubinstein
and the other generous sponsors who made
this event possible
and if you'd like to contribute your
financial support there's some
information about that in the program
before we begin i've been asked to
remind you that these events are being
recorded by the library of congress
which may broadcast them at some future
date
after our author's presentation there
will be time for questions but if you
don't want to become part of the perm
the library's permanent collection
it may be best to let someone else ask
the questions
now many people have the look of
brilliance
there are many people who sound
brilliant
but few people have both of those
qualities and a third most important one
they prove their brilliance
steve call is that rare person
his works speak for itself
he's a two-time winner of the pulitzer
prize once as a reporter for the
washington post for his coverage of the
sec and another time for his book ghost
wars his account of the cia's role in
afghanistan
now he's dean of columbia journalism
school and a staff writer at the new
yorker
i was honored to work under him when he
was managing editor of the washington
post
steve has written eight books these
include an account of the breakup of a t
an exploration of exxon mobil's power
and a history of the bin laden family
his latest book directorate s
is a follow-up to ghost wars it takes us
into the aftermath of the us invasion of
afghanistan in 2001
and the u.s experience over the next 17
years
which can be described as one as one
reviewer put it
best as a period of american ignorance
atrocity and error
reviewers have called the book
impressive and definitive they have
noted the 550 interviews steve conducted
they have praised his literary prowess
but the story steve tells is a
disparating one
as the new york times wrote the topic is
important the treatment compelling the
conclusion is persuasive
but that reviewer andrew basovich noted
that america's policymakers are not
listening and are not taking steve's
reporting to heart
just don't expect anything to change
basevich said concluded sadly
steve is a force for illumination and
understanding of america's past
and present so please welcome me please
join me in welcoming steve call
[Applause]
thank you so much steve thank you all
for coming out
i really enjoyed working with stephen
fantastic colleagues at the washington
post i miss them a lot so i'm always
glad to get back to washington and also
i'm always glad to get back to a city
that has so many people in public
service and engaged in international
policy which are kind of my subjects i
wonder just a quick show of hands how
many people in this room have have been
to afghanistan since 2001 in service in
one way or another
yeah a significant number
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i have about uh
30 minutes to introduce the book to you
so i'm going to have to be efficient you
might notice that's not a thin book
and so the way i try to give you a
flavor of it is uh by giving you a sense
of what it's about where it came from
and what story it tells but then mostly
what are the what are several of the
most important themes in this history
that i can try to draw out and give you
a little bit of flavor for and then i
look forward i'll read a little bit at
one stage as well just to give you a
flavor for some of the reporting on the
ground and i look forward to your
questions
so in
february 1989
the final armored car column of the
limited contingent of soviet forces in
afghanistan as the soviet occupation
army was called
crossed over the friendship bridge of
the amudaria river officially ending the
soviet occupation of afghanistan during
the 1980s
general gromov was the final soviet
commander and he got down from the last
armored personnel carrier and turned his
back on afghanistan and walked out and
was greeted by his son who gave him a
bouquet of flowers that was how the
soviet war ended
in december 2014 the obama
administration thought it was ending the
war in afghanistan although it intended
to stay and hand off
support in an advisory role under
operation resolution support but
nonetheless
the united states at that time thought
that its combat operations direct combat
operations in afghanistan were ending so
they held a ceremony
in a gymnasium
in the bunkered and fortified
headquarters of the international
security assistance force in afghanistan
and kabul
and they handed out they had some
military bans they were but they were
very well inside a an area that they
sometimes had
experience of being rocketed in so they
handed out uh kind of a program for the
ceremony that included instructions
about how to get down on the floor and
cover your head in the event of
rocketing so that was how
the us
war
ended once and then a year later it
started again
and
today as you know we're still actually
in direct combat operations in
afghanistan we're fighting two wars
there one directly against the islamic
state al qaeda and affiliated groups
and then another that advisory and
assist war that that we thought we were
moving into in 2014 so it's been 17
years a lot of frustration a lot of
sacrifice
hundreds of thousands of americans
volunteered over the course of those
years to serve in afghanistan
more than two thousand american soldiers
died as did hundreds of contractors more
than twenty thousand soldiers suffered
injuries
the casualties among afghans and
pakistanis were even greater
the war that that followed the end of
the american invasion in 2001 caused
about 140 000 deaths directly by the end
of 2014 according to estimates by
researchers at brown university and tens
of thousands more since then
and of course afghans and pakistanis
have suffered the most losses even
greater losses
so why over so many years and despite so
many uh efforts and strategies has the
united states
failed to achieve its goals in
afghanistan has it failed to vanquish
the taliban
failed to stabilize the country failed
to create a self-sustaining independent
constitutional republic or democracy of
some sort
it's a long story it's a complicated
story but as i say i want to draw out a
few themes and tell a few stories around
what i think are some of the recurring
problems in the war so the first
is the problem of war aims
why are we there
which was a question that was of course
never really formally addressed before
we invaded afghanistan because the war
was a hurried and improvisational
response to the september 11th attacks
designed to disrupt al qaeda which was
in afghanistan
and had carried out the attacks
substantially from there
to disrupt their leadership before they
could launch what was presumed to be
follow-on attacks and so
the war never really reckoned with what
afghanistan after
the invasion would be because it was
really being conceived within two or
three weeks of the shock of the
september 11th attacks and so in the
subsequent period after the taliban fell
at the end of 2001 and al qaeda largely
escaped afghanistan and migrated into
pakistan the war since then has been
plagued by recurring
arguments and confusion over
war aims i want to talk about that
second thing that has really
been repetitive
although
it was confined to the period when hamid
karzai was
in office
was the failure to consolidate
a relationship with karzai that would
serve american interests
in the transition to a post karzai world
we we really lost our relationship with
karzai and and our investments in
democratic afghan politics also faltered
not only because of our conduct or
decision making afghans had a lot to do
with that too but i think the the story
of the failure of the relationship with
hamid karzai is particularly interesting
because it goes to the big problem of
pakistan
the biggest puzzle
i think for a lot of people who served
in the war and certainly for a lot of
afghans
throughout the war after 2001 and
particularly when the taliban started to
revive around 2004 2005 in seriousness
was why the united states and nato were
willing to accept
the sanctuary and the support that the
taliban enjoyed still enjoy across the
border in pakistan
even when pakistan was receiving
hundreds of millions of dollars in usaid
and
even after it became obvious that the
taliban were prevailing or certainly
working up a pretty bloody stalemate in
afghanistan because of the sanctuary and
the training and the aid that they
enjoyed covertly
from pakistan and from pakistan's
principal intelligence service
inter-services intelligence or isi
the title of the book directorate s
refers to the covert action arm it's
what the american sometimes called the
the covert action arm of isi the
pakistani intelligence service that
works with groups like the taliban
related groups in kashmir
to carry out what pakistan's army sees
as its foreign policy interests in the
region of course the americans knew all
about isi because we had collaborated
with them during the 1980s against the
soviet union along with saudi
intelligence we pumped billions of
dollars into the afghan rebel force
based in pakistan that also prevailed
over the soviet union because it enjoyed
this physical sanctuary and covert aid
that that we participated in
so why why did we fail to recognize isis
revival and why did it turn out to be so
so flummoxing something we can talk
about
all right so that's the real principal
narrative of the book it opens ghost
wars closes on the eve of the 9 11
attacks it's about the
the history between the soviet invasion
and 9 11
and this is intended uh as a second
volume of ghost wars although it's kind
of a funny thing as a writer to write a
second volume of a book that wasn't
intended to be the first of two but
that's kind of what this is and it ends
where ghost wars stops quite
deliberately and comes forward to
something like the present day and has
many of the same
reporting and narrative storytelling
strategies as the first volume
all right so i promised uh to go over
this this subject of war aims
one of the things i mean i was kind of a
beat reporter on the war after 9 11
because i had accidental expertise about
afghanistan i'd been assigned out there
by the washington post as a foreign
correspondent i'd covered the war on the
ground long before 9 11 before anyone
was really very interested in it um but
it was a i became kind of a professional
obsession and a great interest i loved
uh the landscape and the people that i
met in afghanistan and pakistan and i
found the war and the structure of
covert action that shaped so much misery
and radicalism in the region to be an
important subject and one that
fascinated me but after 9 11
because of that background i kept going
back to the region pakistan and
afghanistan doing a lot of reporting
and i and i also was a creature of
washington covering the national
security bureaucracy and interagency
debates about u.s policy in afghanistan
and in the war
and so when i went back to do the
research to really excavate the history
of decision-making in washington about
policy in the afghan war and policy
toward pakistan i was surprised and a
little bit disheartened to encounter
what i didn't fully appreciate as a kind
of beat reporter
which is the repetitive nature of the
debates about why are we in afghanistan
and who is our enemy
the bush administration through several
phases
right up until the last
days and months of the bush
administration convened in a classified
conference room in the eisenhower
executive office building which is next
door to the white house if you're
walking by the white house it's over
there to the right that very ornate
looking building
on the fourth floor and they would
typically spend a whole day wrestling
over what direction to take in
afghanistan they'd have the intelligence
analyst come in in the morning and try
to brief the facts this is what the map
looks like these are these are the
uh the principal ethnic groups here are
the principal factions
and then they would leave and the
policymakers would debate and they'd get
to these basic questions
are the taliban our enemy
there were no afghans on the plains on 9
11.
so far as is known the afghan taliban
have never
carried out a terrorist attack
as an organization against the united
states
in the u.s or in europe
they were attacked initially because
they were correctly seen as providing
sanctuary to ida
their alliance with al qaeda was always
uneasy and debatable
and so in these policy decisions
starting in 2006 repeating in 2008 and
in 2009 and in 2012 and in 2014
the best minds in the us government the
best informed south asia policy makers
would
return to this conference room write up
white papers try to develop
recommendations to the president and one
of the questions they kept returning to
is what are our vital interests
in afghanistan that justify the kinds of
sacrifices that we ask young men and
women in uniform to make over there
and
an example would be in 2009 during the
first year of the obama administration
new group came in went back to the same
conference room picked up the white
papers that the bush administration had
left behind went back to this question
and they were clear-eyed about what the
question should be as taxpayers you
would want them to be asking what vital
interests really justify this kind of
military sacrifice
and they worked on that for weeks and
months and in the end they identified
two
one was
al qaeda which was still
carrying out international attacks from
the from the region against the united
states tempting attacks inside the
united states
also in europe
and elsewhere
and
the second was the security of
pakistan's nuclear weapons
because pakistan has about 100 nuclear
weapons it has a lot of radical groups
on its soil and the nightmare scenario
would be
if somehow pakistan became so
destabilized that these weapons fell
into
the wrong hands
but consider this contradiction the
first of half a dozen that we can review
over the next 20 minutes
neither al qaeda nor pakistan's nuclear
weapons were in afghanistan in 2009
where the president was about to send a
hundred thousand troops
so if the vital interests are in
pakistan why are we fighting a war next
door in afghanistan
the president and his advisers were
smart enough to understand this is a
contradiction so they wrestled with it
and they said well
it's sort of an indirect
reason because if afghanistan falls
apart then
al qaeda will come back into afghanistan
and
that may also destabilize pakistan
so we've got to shore up this neighbor
in order to pursue the vital interests
that are next door
i don't know i mean as a parent
sending a child into harm's way that
feels a little bit indirect to me as a
as a war aim
well the other war aim then that might
justify this sort of sacrifice is you
are going to fight the taliban you're
going to prevent the taliban from
consolidating the momentum which by 2009
it had quite a lot of on the ground in
afghanistan
but the
policymakers and include particularly
during the early obama years were really
divided about whether the taliban should
be understood as an enemy of the united
states partly for the reasons that i
described they're indigenous to
afghanistan it was pointed out in these
debates
they are part of the fabric of southern
and eastern afghanistan they have they
have not declared war against the united
states they're abhorrent their ideas are
abhorrent
we certainly don't want them to take
power
but are they an enemy
the truth was that president obama did
not believe that the united states
should attempt to fight a forever war
against the taliban that there was
neither the political clock in the
united states nor the resources nor the
prospect of military victory to justify
such an endeavor
but his generals had sold him on the
idea of a counter-insurgency war that
could succeed in afghanistan the way it
was perceived to have succeeded in
baghdad
after the surge there in 2006.
and so the president was reluctant to
uh at least initially
that's a funnier conversation than
afghanistan
let's make some noise in here
sorry
people are
it's hard to get a laugh out of fighting
and dying but we'll keep trying
anyway
there's a scene where
the president basically makes it known
through his white house aides that he
doesn't want to try to fight this
forever war against the taliban and so
his aides go into this secure conference
room or the situation room one day and
they say have we ever really said
that it was our aim to defeat the
taliban
and the pentagon representatives are
appalled and the next day they come back
with a big powerpoint deck that shows
all the different statements that
american presidents and senators have
made
about our intention to vanquish the
taliban from the face of the earth he
said you may not want to fight this war
but you've said you've signed up for it
and and so yes we have declared uh our
interest in defeating it but then when
the
troop surge announcements were made if
you parse that language it's very
careful not to declare that we intend to
defeat the taliban on the battlefield
the the war aim was to reduce or reverse
the taliban's momentum to create space
for afghan forces to take the lead and
and essentially
a kind of vietnamization of the afghan
war and that was achieved it still has
been achieved today the war is a
stalemate now just as it was in 2007 one
of the episodes the book describes
repeatedly is this these very popular
classified maps that the cia would
produce called the district assessments
which were derived from a similar
mapping exercise carried out during the
vietnam war they would take all of
approximately afghanistan's
approximately 400 districts
administrative districts and color code
them based on the latest intelligence
and
open information as to whether or not
they were controlled by the taliban
controlled by the afghan government
contested or locally controlled by some
other warlord
and
essentially they would come in and
unfurl these maps and everyone would
pour over them looking for subtle
changes the reality is they haven't
changed color in 10 years they're made
every six months and things move around
and green appears here and red appears
there the war is stalemated and it's
still emitted because
the taliban have no air force and they
have no answer for the u.s air force so
they can't mass very successfully
but also neither the
nato-led troops which at their peak
numbered 150 000 in afghanistan in 2010
nor um
the afghan forces after we reduced our
presence
has had an answer for the sanctuary in
pakistan for the role of isi in
supporting the taliban in the war or for
the taliban's coercive control of quite
a lot of rural districts particularly in
the south and east
losing hamid karzai again you know as a
beat reporter i i'd covered jamie karzai
for a long time over the years i've
interviewed him a couple of times
watched him been to press conferences
he's a fascinating figure
and certainly was as he as he became the
unexpected president of afghanistan
after 2001
and i thought i understood
him reasonably well i was aware
certainly by the time i was working on
this book that he had gained a
reputation as being this
very unstable individual who was
constantly going off and attacking the
united states and and kind of involved
in conspiracy theories and that sort of
thing
um and again i was surprised when i kind
of excavated as many of the private
conversations that he had with his own
cabinet or with the americans that he
was very consistent over the years about
one thing every time an american would
come to visit him he would say
you're not doing enough to put pressure
on pakistan these sanctuaries are
unacceptable and isi's interference and
the war is going to make the war
unwinnable why are you not doing this
why are you not why are you treating
them as if this isn't going on
and the americans at first would say
well you don't think you understand
president musharraf who is then seen as
a reliable ally of the united states
he's a friend he's trying to do his best
later the americans agreed that isi was
a problem but they felt they couldn't
put too much pressure on pakistan
because after all pakistan itself was
convulsed by internal violence
caused in part by the migration of al
qaeda into pakistan they had the worst
domestic terrorism they've ever
experienced in 2009 2010 and if a vital
interest the united states was
preventing pakistan's nuclear weapons
from getting into the wrong hands he
couldn't very well go in and exacerbate
the
almost civil war that pakistan was
experiencing at that point nonetheless
we kept confusing karzai by kind of
fluffing off his question
in the summer of 2008 then candidate
obama flew into afghanistan on a
campaign visit and he went to meet
karzai and his cabinet in this cabinet
really they all didn't like each other
very much they rarely cooperated on much
but they all got together before the
meeting and said let's agree to
emphasize to
possible president obama that it's all
about isi it's all about pakistan so
when each of them went around the table
and said something they all said you
really have to focus on this problem
because the sanctuary is going to make
the war unwinnable
and when the united states didn't do
anything about it
worse when the united states made it
clear to karzai that it thought maybe
pakistan was actually more important to
the united states than afghanistan he
understandably became deeply confused
there's a scene in the book where
vice president joe biden goes out
early on
in the obama administration to meet with
karzai and the obama administration came
in and a lot of administrations come in
no matter which party it is they think
whatever the last guys did was exactly
wrong so we're going to do the opposite
and one of the syndromes in this case
was that the obama folks thought
that the bush
administration particularly president
bush personally had coddled karzai had
spent too much time holding his hand had
had accommodated too much corruption too
much drug dealing and that it was time
to get tough on him so biden was sent
out to deliver this message you know the
the era of the friendly video conference
is over you you got to clean up your act
and you can't expect
us to accommodate you the way the last
administration did so he goes into this
private meeting with karzai karzai
starts the meeting by saying
you know mr vice president you really
need to do more about pakistan you
really need to do more about isi
and
biden replies mr president
pakistan is 50 times more important in
the united states than afghanistan
so maybe not the most diplomatic way to
put pressure on karzai but you know in a
lot of uh
south asia and certainly a lot of
similar parts of the world it's common
to sink into conspiracy thinking and the
way it went for karzai was when he
looked at the fact that the united
states wasn't putting any pressure on
pakistan and that pakistan was by the
admission of many american generals and
intelligence officers that its role in
the war was critical
he began to think well the united states
must want pakistan to be reviving the
taliban he must want pakistan to be
destabilizing afghanistan he must want
the americans must want this war to
grind on so that they can justify having
a long-term military presence in the
country
this is the kind of confusion that you
kind of create now
diplomat after diplomat general after
general would go to karzai and say no mr
president there's no such conspiracy
we're just doing our best to try to keep
this war going in the right direction
but karzai was absolutely convinced that
the americans after a certain point were
deliberately
allowing isi to create this war so that
they could justify a long-term presence
at one point a guy named jim dobbins in
2013 he goes out and meets with karzai
try to talk him out of this idea
he says mr president by now you've got
the snowden material
the wikileaks
millions of documents
read them can you see any trace of this
plan this conspiracy that you're
attributing to us and karsai looks at
him and says
well maybe you don't know the plan maybe
you're not briefed
you know there is a deep state in
america he said
okay a lot of the book tries to describe
how these decisions cascaded built one
on another how all these
misunderstandings developed at the
highest levels among
decision makers in washington and
islamabad and kabul but i also felt that
i should try to write about the war as
it was experienced on the ground
and particularly after the united states
launched this counterinsurgency campaign
in southern afghanistan in 2010 2009
2010 2011.
it was a war very distant war uh didn't
get uh quite all of the attention the
reality of it i don't think quite soaked
through was a volunteer army fighting in
very difficult terrain but it was the
product of a kind of faith in
counter-insurgency expeditionary
encounter insurgency as i mentioned
followed out of the perceived success in
in baghdad and if you were in town if
you were in national security circles in
washington circa 2009 2010 it was like a
bubble it was like a bitcoin or
some other kind of sense
self-reinforcing sense that this idea is
going to solve it we're going to go out
there we're going to run this
counter-insurgency campaign connecting
people to their government
walking through villages
fighting it out one path at a time and
it turned out in places like kandahar to
be a very violent war
and so i looked for a way to tell the
story through one unit's experience in
the heart of the campaign
and i chose um
the part of the campaign that was fought
in the so-called green zone to the to
the west of our of kandahar which is the
taliban's birthplace significant city in
the south of afghanistan it's called the
green zone because though it's desert
there's the arghandab river flows
through it and irrigation is made
possible much of the year
through this river and the vegetation
around in this green zone is incredibly
thick that's grape orchards with
uh drying houses and berms almost worse
than norman normandy in terms of terrain
to try to fight in
and foliage that's almost jungle-like
with in the canopy that it creates
10-foot marijuana plants being a feature
of this as big marijuana farming
industry one of the jobs the americans
had was to go out and cut down these
10-foot plants and then set them on fire
which was not always objected to as duty
but it was uh the taliban had been
embedding in this zone for for years and
years and had built an incredible
infrastructure and that and the purpose
of the counterinsurgency campaign was to
go in and knock them out once and for
all so i'll just read you
um a little passage from from that
campaign the flavor of it
so the initial phase of colonel art
candarian's campaign in the green zone
wasn't much different from that of the
us army and the american west during the
19th century build forts in indian
country and poke around
forward american units detains
suspected insurgents and used retinal
scanners to log them into classified
databases but interrogations in a human
intelligence collection in kandahar that
summer rarely produced insights besides
the known fact that many taliban
fighters were from or trained in
pakistan
so
the platoons that i write about were
former artillery units that had been
converted to infantry because during
this period of the war the united states
military was so stressed by the
cascading consequences of fighting hard
in iraq and afghanistan at the same time
that they were piecing together task
forces out of different units and they
were asking artillery men to fight close
infantry
patrol wars
with a lot of ieds and implanted
explosives and and this is uh
you know a lot of these artillery men
had been trained to fight with big guns
on bases at a remote distance they were
engineers and they weren't used to this
they so they would build these
outposts in the middle of the green zone
barely being able to see five feet over
the wall and then they would go out and
patrol on foot by contact trying to just
draw the taliban into contact
platoons depended on their most
experienced sergeants to survive
sergeant josh strickland had served two
tours in iraq and one in afghanistan
before joining third platoon a battery
of the 1 320th the artillery misfits
during the first couple of weeks of at
combat outpost nolan strickland's
patrols could not walk a hundred yards
without hitting an ied or getting lit up
by taliban from several sides
listening to the enemy radio talk they
learned the enemy knew they were
artillery not infantry
in general strickland thought
the lowest ranking first time soldiers
adjusted to the stress better than the
more experienced artillery men because
the rookies had no expectations from
prior deployments
because of strickland's experience and
uncanny ability to avoid ieds soldiers
continually asked him to walk point on
their patrols he chose to walk 10 to 15
feet ahead of everyone else so that he
could carefully identify the best route
and so that if he did make a mistake it
would cost one life instead of several
he was ultimately wounded in medevac to
kandahar airfield four times each time
as he recovered in the hospital a doctor
would ask strickland if he wanted to go
back or go home
what am i going to say he thought he
went back
day after day they shouldered their
loads stepped out on presence patrols
and hoped for the best they walked past
villagers near their outposts who were
neither helpful nor hostile one elder
near strickland's base kept a pigeon
that he would let fly every time a
platoon departed apparently to let the
taliban know they were on the march
by july ieds and the escalating
casualties had rattled even the most
experienced infantry men
every soldier carried 70-90 pounds of
gear water and ammunition they patrolled
at night to avoid the sun
it drank water continually to stave off
dehydration
the ieds were so thick around the
bulldogs encampment that they had to
clear a hundred yards at a time from the
walls out a lot of soldiers struggled
with the stress
the first platoon of the one three
twentieth started out with nineteen men
after three patrols they had six
eighty percent
eighty percent of bravo company's
personnel had to be replaced during
strickland's tour because of combat
deaths severed limbs concussions or
other injuries
now you think of those percentages i
mean that sounds like battle of the
bulge
wasn't it wasn't present in american
life
that part of the war
and one of the reasons uh that i want to
finish on the last theme i want to touch
on
was because we really didn't have a
national debate
about the war
during the time that these sacrifices
were being
sought
and
we also
failed to reckon with the kind of
political strategy
that was necessary
given the history of wars of this kind
to really fashion any kind of exit from
the war that would be sustainable
one of the contradictions that keeps
recurring in history is that every
general who goes out to command they
command usually for a year at a time
maybe two years at a time if they're if
they stay for a long while
every general who'll go out for the
american effort will say
there is no military victory possible
against the taliban
the only way this war will end will be
through political negotiations and some
kind of settlement
and yet again and again
military action is israel is resourced
ahead of political strategy
and there is very little uh effort of a
serious kind made to
bring
the regional powers the great powers the
international system into a negotiation
to stabilize the war
the book recounts this very interesting
secret negotiation the obama
administration carried out with the
taliban
between 2010 and 2013 it failed for a
bunch of reasons the trump
administration is trying something
similar now
but
it was always treated as a kind of hail
mary pass and never given the serious
international attention that for example
accompanied the efforts to
cap iran's
nuclear program with the p5 powers and
europe and everyone else involved
it's kind of a tragedy that we keep
repeating
the same strategy again and again and
expecting a different result while
asking for such large sacrifices from
our own soldiers and those of our allies
thank you for listening i take a few
questions thanks
[Applause]
thank you for your remarks really
appreciated that uh in your discussion
you talked about american aims
what about the pakistani aims and
specifically pakistan's interest in
india and how that plays out in
afghanistan
um great question so and it's a big part
of the book um short version
pakistan's foreign policy and military
policies of course very heavily
influenced by its army so the outlook of
civilian politicians is much less
relevant
when you talk about something like
afghanistan
and as you say the pakistan army's
principal concern
is
india in which it believes seeks
pakistan's
demilitarization or dismemberment
and
the pakistan army discovered with our
help during the 1980s that this
asymmetric strategy of supporting
islamist militia groups against
india in the region was a successful way
for a smaller
country with a smaller population and a
less powerful economy to hold its own to
deter india
and so
that's been their historical strategy
and afghanistan has been part of it is
why pakistan was one of only three
countries in the world that recognized
the taliban government when it ruled
afghanistan in the 1990s they see india
kind of using afghanistan to sort of
encircle pakistan
and then they have a direct
confrontation to their east
the
supper question is why did pakistan go
back
into partnership with the taliban
after
2005 2006 because for all of pervez
musharraf's limitations as pakistan's
military leader and president there was
a period in 2002 2003 where he was
arresting a lot of al qaeda figures
cooperating a lot with the united states
on counterterrorism
looking not to particularly get involved
with the taliban i think probably just
hoping they would fade away
but several years later it became clear
first to frontline american officers and
intelligence collectors and then
eventually to the whole cabinet that
isi was back in action that they were
going back to the same old strategies
they'd used before and so why why did
the high command make that decision 2004
2005 2006 was kind of a mystery that i
worked on in my research
i'm not saying i don't think i've solved
it entirely but i think there were a
couple of important factors
one was
that the pakistanis sense of our
involvement in afghanistan and with them
over the years is we're not reliable we
come we go we come in when we need
something as soon as we have it then we
go and in 2004 2005 we were off fighting
in iraq
and the bush administration's view was
that iraq was the main effort and that
afghanistan was at peace and they turned
over security in the country to nato
allies and declined to resource a
significant american commitment to the
country and so when the pakistani
general saw the dutch coming in to
provide security in southern afghanistan
and they saw the americans concentrating
in iraq they basically said to
themselves we've seen this movie before
they're going home they're leaving us
with this neighborhood and india is
going to take advantage of this if we
don't
defend our interests that was one reason
i think the second was around this time
the united states did this big strategic
nuclear deal with india
india is a natural 21st century ally of
the united states in a lot of ways and
they wanted
india to to feel rewarded in strategic
partnership
but
they essentially said to the indian
government we forgive you for having a
nuclear weapons program um and and you
you're now
legitimate as a partner of ours and they
and we said to the pakistanis at the
same time you're not getting this deal
you're not reliable enough you give away
your nuclear weapons through aq con and
so forth pakistani said okay you made
yourself clear
um india is your
your strategic ally for the 21st century
we're your rent a cop
you know
we're going to get after our own
interest and i think that's a lot of why
they they went back to pursuing the
taliban's revival yes thanks so much for
your presentation my question is do you
think that the debate on this war and on
many recent wars would be enhanced if we
reintroduced the draft it's a really
interesting question i mean you know the
the strength of the american military uh
as an institution as a journalist if you
encounter it you can see um many of its
great strengths and they're rooted in
the in the revival of a volunteer army
um after the debacle of the vietnam war
and the effects it had on the on the uh
military as an institution
but um i'm so struck at how segregated
the experience of sacrifice has been in
both wars because of the geography of
volunteerism in the country
and i do think that a lot of the
populism and the disgust that the
country has expressed about its
decision-making elites particularly in
some of the states and communities that
volunteered to follow leaders into these
wars is located in a in a kind of
uneven
understanding of the failures of these
wars of the of the promises betrayed and
and of the price paid even where the
sacrifice is seen as noble the
extraordinary price that is paid by
people coming home
uh with with missing limbs and and
broken uh broken spirits from repeated
concussions and so forth so
um i i'm
personally i kind of
it's not fashionable in the zip code
where i live but i think national public
service uh is a is a is a good policy
and it doesn't have to all be
conscripted military service to be
successful but
these kinds of sacrifices should not be
isolated from our shared experience as
citizens and they are they were in this
case yes
your description of isi in pakistan
makes it sound sort of uh
not to be facetious but like the deep
state of pakistan
so
two questions what what is imran khan's
relationship going to be to isi and
secondly coming back to
psy hersch's alternative
uh scenario for the the uh capture of
the killing of
al-qaeda's
bin laden do you put any credence in
that
so um
imran khan is a really fascinating
figure i wrote a big profile about him
in the new yorker in 2012 i think when
he was first bursting onto the scene um
he was a very entertaining person to
hang around with and write about so if
you are interested in him
you can find that online
at the time i went back and read it when
he
became prime minister and i was
surprised at that time he really spoke
pretty boldly about the army which is
not a
thing to do in pakistan if you want a
political future he was critical of the
army very openly at that time
but i think he's seen now as having
become a partner of the army and the
army has made a very
uh clear decision into an understandable
one
that it doesn't want to rule pakistan
directly the reputational costs the
institutional costs the costs in the
international system are high
better to rule indirectly through
civilian pop politicians who can deal
with the domestic problems of the
economy of negotiating with the imf of
all of the
problems that pakistan perennially
endures
and so imran khan i think has been
uh willing to cooperate or to share
space with the army um you know there
are debates about how much of a lackey
of the army he is but i think the record
is he's he's stopped criticizing them
and he's accepted their clear
kind of framework of support for him to
take power will he be able to accomplish
anything
i'm i'm doubtful
and i i think he might be able to do a
few things domestically
particularly with his anti-corruption
drives but in foreign policy uh
clearly that belongs to the army and i
don't if he tries to move in that
direction every civilian politician who
has tried to challenge the army's ideas
about regional policy and and uh foreign
policy has um
lost office in in a coup or in a kind of
indirect electoral coup
so he knows that history that goes back
30 40 years
uh hershey's story i mean psy is a
american legend and a colleague and
someone who i respect a great deal and
so
um
all i can say is that i researched that
same subject and i didn't see evidence
for the the
the account that he obtained from the
unknown sources because they're they're
just
background sources i i didn't find those
sources you know so
he does have a record sometimes of
reporting things that seem
couldn't possibly be it turns out it's
true
so i you know in pakistan i'm willing to
believe anything
about pakistan but i i i really worked
that thing pretty hard and i i don't see
the evidence for those
for those claims um
do i have time for one more wrap it up
i'm told i've got a card that says
literally wrap it up
so uh we're gonna have the last word oh
thank you so much and i wanna apologize
if i offend anybody because i probably
as probably you can hear i'm i'm not
from here i'm originally from poland
live in canada now
so i hope my question won't sound like
hostile but i i think like especially
like i remember watching the movie uh
charlie wilson were many many years ago
and there was the scene when i think
charlie goes to like i think it was cia
or government and he asked about like
afghanistan or like central asia
department and there's like three kids
from fresh out of college and and i
think what really is like considering
the in the american involvement they're
not
now like i think sometimes especially
people from other countries with all the
respect for like like soldiers fighting
american soldiers and canadian soldiers
and other countries soldiers fighting
and sacrificing their life is there
really like some kind of a government
body that like has like a really deep
knowledge and understanding of the area
it's a great question i mean i think um
[Music]
expertise about afghanistan and pakistan
was scant on 911 and it was a problem
there really wasn't anyone in the
cabinet who had experience of the region
first i'm not sure that there was anyone
in the cabinet where the senior ranks of
the administration had actually been in
afghanistan on as of 9 11. colin powell
richard armitage at the state department
knew the region reasonably well but
primarily through collaborating with the
pakistan army during the first gulf war
and so their perspective was very much
located around the stabilizing force of
the pakistan army
and that influenced some of the early
debates there were cia people who knew
quite a lot about
the resistance to the taliban because
they've been working with them and they
did get to the table and offered some
initial advice but as a broad matter i
think
the failure to see
isi go back into action until it was
pretty much too late in 2007 2008 was
partly a function of the lack of high
level
understanding about the complexities of
the war and the complexities of the
region a lot of it more of it was about
the distraction of iraq but i think that
was a factor and then for those of us
who would who had been working on this
and and were really engaged with it it
was frustrating sometimes to think that
our government really didn't get it at
some level
by 2008 by 2007 2008 i wouldn't say that
anymore i mean i knew enough of the
people who were making decisions the
army had been out in the field you had
people multiple tours you had a lot of
dhari speakers and pashto speakers going
into the military now
you had a cabinet that had finally
really spent a lot of time with this
problem and i think by 2000 2007 2008
the
the cabinet level
decision makers yeah they did understand
what the problem was
and i used to go around to to friends in
2009 2010 i was working down here at the
time and said you know finally everybody
in the system understands what's going
on
the problem is that doesn't make it
possible to solve it
no nobody you know that that clarity has
not produced insights about how to how
to
untie this not and and you still see
that happening today
um but yeah there the expertise uh
accumulated at a great cost and it
wasn't the expertise of a solution
thank you all
fall is a busy time for book fairs and
festivals across the country here's a
look at some that are come